joining us is former prime minister of
Pakistan Imran Khan thank you so much
for joining DW news Asia and Sir of
course I want to start by first asking
how you're healing from your injuries
and do you expect a full recovery
uh I'm uh healing I have two bullet
wounds in My Thai and one in my
shinborne
uh all three have been removed and now
my bones cracks so it needs uh four to
six weeks rest I can't put weight on it
until it recovers the bullets from my
tires have been taken out and they are
flesh Foods so full recovery hopefully
in four weeks time
that's excellent too no now
um you've accused the Prime Minister
himself along with the interior minister
in the country's intelligence service of
being behind this assassination attempt
and those are very serious accusations
um what kind of proof have you been able
to provide and and why are you saying
this
uh well first of all let me explain that
the people who are threatened the most
who would want me to be eliminated uh is
the current government
because uh since the last expansions by
government has been out of office or
through a conspiracy
um the party's popularity is
unprecedented no parties has been has
had such public acceptability as mine
so we have one out of 37 by-elections in
the past five months my party has won 29
so 75 of by elections we won and Royal
opinion polls we are sort of by far uh
ahead so they are threatened they know
elections they cannot compete and so
their motive was to get me out of the
way they tried otherwise they tried to
disqualify me put terrorism cases on me
uh oppressing our party journalism
journalists hounded who were trying to
portray our point of view one is the
best investigative journalist Sharif was
murdered in Kyrie 100 out of Pakistan
uh so this was a plan to get me out of
the way so those two and let me tell you
the Prime Minister but so very quickly
what you've provided is contextual
um there are certainly people who would
benefit from harming uh you so but it is
a little bit like Sherlock Holmes it's
deductive uh you believe there's a plot
based on a pattern of what critics have
said but what is the hard evidence
because what you've provided is
circumstantial
look
I know these three people were involved
because I knew about the plot the plot
started two months back they
decided to uh bump me off by saying a
religious fanatic had killed me so two
months uh back they started this
campaign it was uh the video was made by
these intelligence agency it went down
onto the politicians on the state media
where the consistently started this
campaign that uh I offended
I committed blasphemy and these
religious settlements were upset so I
then exposed this on the 24th of
September on the 7th of October in a
public uh a big rally saying exactly
they said this is the plot and they will
have be bumped up by a religious fanatic
pretending that I offended I committed
blasphemy no so you were warned about
this you were warned about this and so
you believe that as a result of being
warned then it has to be uh the Prime
Minister and the military apparatus uh
behind this I guess my thing is is there
no way that this was a lone shooter
absolutely no way
Melissa first of all let me get it right
these two the Prime Minister and the
interior Minister were involved with a
massacre called The Mortal Town Massacre
where the gun had the Police gun down 12
people and 60 people got bullet pools
both of them have been accused
of extrajudicial killing so it's killing
is not new for them as for the military
at the intelligence guy that's they were
in cahoots that's where the video
started we can we have a passion how the
whole thing started I warned them and
remember I was three and a half years of
prime minister the intelligence agencies
worked under me so not only did I get
information from within the agencies
which I will tell the investigation but
also I know how they work so I know
that's why I want I told the country six
weeks ago that this is what was going to
happen and this followed exactly the
same script
and so when if you knew about this I
want to ask about the security because
when I look at the videos of you doing
this long march there doesn't seem to be
a lot of security did you just ignore
the warnings or did you decide to just
take extraordinary risks uh to your own
life but also to those who support you
look
last six months I have been in the
public I've had
60 public rallies you know almost a
record and then uh this March
so there was always going to be
addressed so many of the rally before I
was holding a rally they would say your
life is a threat there's a terrorist
threat this went on for six months now
I had the options do I stay at home and
stop this Injustice that has happened to
Pakistan where they're prolonged the
biggest Crooks of this country who've
been looting the country for 30 years
they belong on us and we we expect it to
sit quietly like a herd of sheep or were
we going to stand up to the Injustice so
I decided that whatever the risk I would
go out in the public so they were always
going to be arrested but I know who was
being threatened and I know who plotted
it and that's why I want an independent
investigation because only we will be
able to provide all the circumstantial
evidence and by the way the cover-up
which followed and we use asked a
question
that in their narrative in their
narrative there was a one shooter
because a religious fanatic one guy shot
me now they've done the forensics
already we know they were these shooters
because there was a someone shooting
from front they found two different
types of bullets so already that
narrative has blown apart that there was
a lone guy who did it himself there was
another shooter from the buildings and
and and firing different bullets
so is it not possible that there was a
religious fanatic I mean do you think
that there is a problem in the country
with religious fanaticism or does that
not exist
there is every country has Fanatics we
all have a little lonely guys but this
was not a religious fanatic they've done
his profile the guy does not fit into
the description of a religious fanatic
he didn't even say his prayers the
social media guys have done all the uh
background checks where he lived and so
on he was not a religious fanatic this
was a trained shooter and and the theory
blows apart because now it's confirmed
that another guy was shooting from the
front with different bullets
now the reason why I keep focusing on
this is that um you know I wonder what
if it turned out you were wrong then
these act very serious accusations you
are making that of course the Prime
Minister has denied these accusations as
has the intelligence Service as has the
military and essentially if if there was
an independent investigation and they
found out that you were wrong that would
essentially make you a liar
um and so you're putting yourself out
there one thing though is that you are
really attacking the establishment you
were Prime Ministers these officials
were still around then you got along
with them then so my question is why
didn't you clean house at that time when
you were in power these people that you
are now saying are the problem with the
country
Melissa number one
you're talking about making serious
allegations I know what happened
I know what was going on I predicted it
six weeks before I predict I in a public
alley I I the whole script I narrated
this this is what they're doing this is
a they're going into the media making it
out it's a religious fanatic and this is
what they'll do if they followed the
script I know who was at board the
intelligence guy
the guy is known he has a background he
has a background of being someone who we
call Dirty Harry who goes around bumping
off people we know these three guys and
Whenever there is an independent
investigation these three will be
involved now my other point is that
these three now had all the
investigation investigating agencies are
under them how am I going to get any
proper investigation with these guys
sitting on top that's why I've gone to
the Chief Justice of Pakistan and have
asked him that he should form an
independent inquiry and I know what
happened listen I was in power for three
and a half years I know how the
government works I know how the
intelligence agencies work and these
guys came in the intelligence agencies
guys when I was removed so these are not
the ones who was when I was there but I
know how the intelligence agencies work
in this country got it now um you are
doing this March you're resuming it
um is part of your goal here to bring
down the system because if you're as
popular as you say and the by-election
certainly suggests that why don't you
wait until the next election why are you
trying to force this to happen and now
can't you wait until next year you will
still likely be as popular as you say
next year if that's what you believe
Melissa it's not about me being popular
and we're in the elections we will win
the elections inshallah whenever they
are held point is Pakistan is going down
we are now nearing default My worry is
that by the time these criminals who've
been put who've been imposed on us by
the time they go the country might go to
a point of no return what we are seeing
is our economy is stacked all economic
indicators have gone down exports
economic growth agricultural growth
everything is heading down rupees
falling reserves going down
we are heading into a dark tunnel the
only thing the only way out of this are
free and fair elections why because when
you free and fair elections you will
have a government for five years that
brings in political stability which
doesn't exist right now and there is no
political stability
listen Melissa if you're not economy
listen listen economy can only stabilize
if you have political stability because
only then the investors come and only
then people have confidence in the
system when no one knows how long this
government is going to last even the
government doesn't know the economy has
done completely
so I take your point that time is of
absolute Essence I feel like there's a
calculus that you have to make right
that's quite tough for you as well which
is uh by doing this March some critics
would say that you're actually creating
more political chaos you're making the
calculus that actually uh the the
short-term chaos will reap long-term
benefits if you can put pressure to bear
in terms of an election sooner rather
than later uh Mr Khan I want to express
how your March has looked beyond
Pakistan's borders I'm sitting here in
Berlin uh you left office following a no
confidence vote and now you're marching
on on the capitol uh choosing not to
wait for the election so to some to some
it doesn't look like a protest it looks
like an attempt to take back power and
uh that you're using populism to do so
from the outside there are critics who
say that this is reminiscent of the
likes of jerobo sonaro in Brazil Donald
Trump in the U.S Rodrigo duterte in the
Philippines or Marcos Jr now in the
Philippines would it be fair to include
you in that bunch
Point number one
uh matching to the capital what is
called the marsh
there were three long marches against me
when I was the Prime Minister we didn't
stop them we didn't think it threatened
my democracy because peaceful public
protests are part of democracy my right
so firstly it is within the Constitution
it is when you feel that there is
something wrong going on as a Democrat
it is your right to protest like you do
in Germany and all over Europe secondly
my government was removed not some
constitutional legal way
they paid a million dollars
of black money was spent to buy 20 of my
members of parliament it was
straightforward
something illegal I mean if you it was
an election it was auctioned they were
they were buying M A's and it was not
hidden the whole country knows the going
rate when this with the spent on my
members of parliament so that is
unconstitutional so it was my right to
process secondly the people who have
come on imposed on us 61 of them are
unveil sixty percent of the cabinet is
on bail on corruption cases and what
they have done is while the economy has
gone down they have given themselves
immunity from corruption this doesn't
happen in a democracy so what we are
doing is our right to protest against
the Injustice that is going on in this
country that their five billion dollars
worth of corruption cases which they
were supposed they are they're charged
with they have given themselves immunity
so that's one of the reasons why we're
marching because it is in which
democracy doesn't happen can you imagine
in Germany that a bunch of legislators
come in and have their corporate cases
waived off by passing a legislation it
can't happen anywhere
so you're talking about corruption but I
go back to the fact that you were in
power what would you have done
differently if you're talking about so
many people who are corrupt do you have
any regrets from your leadership your
prior leadership in terms of not being
able to Tamp down corruption the way
that you're you're talking about right
now
well Melissa Wonder great
uh I came in with a 10 majority a
coalition government we government
and what I did not what I could not do
was impose rule of law corruption is is
it a symptoms when there you do not have
rule of law rule of law means when you
have powerful Crooks who are above law
which is what has happened now these
people who've been plundering these
ruling Elite who've been stealing money
for 30 years with massive corruptial
cases have come into the parliament of
waves of the corrupted cases so what I
could not do is that the accountability
Bureau was not controlled by me it was
controlled by the establishment and so I
did not have the power to bring the big
Crooks under the rule of law and I could
not hold them accountable and so
uh so you're ineffective I mean the
reason why developing world is poor is
because the ruling Elites are above law
and I couldn't succeed in bringing them
uh under the rule of law
Mr Imran Khan we've run out of time
thank you so much for joining us